هنا مسقط راس ميسي حيث الامنيات العريضه
بعودته اليها مع الكاس الذهبيه المدينه
التي تقع على بعد 300 كيلو متر شمال بين
سايرس امتلات بالجداريات التي تحمل صور
ميسي خاصه في هذا الحي حيث نشا قبل
الانتقال الى برشلونه
ولكن لا نعلم ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث لا
يمكننا حتى ان نتخيلك كيف سيكون شكل الحي
اذا فزنا باللقب
على بعدي بضعه شوارع من مدرسه ميسي
الابتدائيه وقف الاطفال امام لوحه جداريه
كبيره لميسي لالتقاط صوره في يوم تخرجهم
نحن سعداء جدا ميسي لاعب عملاق ونشكره على
كل ما يفعله للارجنتين ونحن فخورون بذلك
وبالاخص بوجود ميسي حتى يتوج مسيرته
الكرويه
وقد فعل ما يكفي لكسب محبه واحترام الجميل
معقوده عليه لقياده منتخب التانجو بلقب
المونديال الثالث وكتابه الفصل الاخير من
حكايه مسيرته الاستثنائيه بحروف من ذهب